- So I propose this,
you and I fight one man and one man.
We fight in our armies stead.
If I lose,
my men will leave
this place forthwith and forever.
You will have my head.
If I win,
I will assume this kingdom's crown
upon your father's death.
What say you?
- Are you scared you're angry?
- What say you?
- Are you scared of this battle?
There is no shame of it.
- Save your men.
- You save your own men.
You came here to me!
Surrender to me!
- I cannot do that.
- Well then boy,
let us make famous
that field out there.
This little village of Agincourt.
That will forever mark the
site of your callow disgrace.
(metal clinking)
(suspenseful music)
(speaking foreign language)
- Archers.
- Archers!
(suspenseful music)
- Now.
- Draw!
(suspenseful music)
- Loose!
(arrows pinging)
(horses neighing)
(arrows smacking)
(men yelling)
- [Knight] Halt, break.
(suspenseful music)
(horn honking)
- Loose!
(arrows pinging)
(arrows smacking)
(men yelling)
- On me!
(metal clanging)
(men yelling)
(horses neighing)
(metal clanging)
(men smacking)
(men yelling)
(horn wailing)
(horse neighing)
- Come then.
(sword clinking)
King of England.
(metal clinking)
(man yelling)
Oh ah.
(dramatic music)
Ha, ah, oh.
Huh ah.
(man groaning)
(men yelling)
(metal clanking)
(men cheering)
(dramatic music)